[Music]  for generations  [Music]  my family has served and protected our  city  [Music]  by following traditional paths  [Music]  my grandmother devoted herself to the  fox spirit  who taught her the ancient way of  healing  whereas my mother has chosen the path of  the blade  [Music]  passing down time-honored skills  through training  and discipline  [Music]  i knew  each of them wanted me to follow her  path  but  i couldn't choose  training quiets my mind  and opens me to the fox spirit's  guidance  [Applause]  and my bond with her  lets me protect those  who can't fight for themselves  they both made me feel whole  and they both felt like home  for generations  my family has served and protected our  city  by following traditional paths  [Music]  me  [Music]  i made my own  [Music]  you